les affiches des candidats à la
présidentielle s'étale dans les rues
désertes de lisbonne
à deux jours du premier tour le scrutin
ne suscite que peu d'enthousiasmé chez
les portugais
aucun meeting ni rassemblement n'est
possible depuis une semaine et la mise
en place d'un deuxième confinement
générale et malgré le contexte le
scrutin fixé par la loi électorale n'a
pas été reporté selon les sondages
d'issue du vote s'annonce sans grande
surprise le président sortant marcel de
souza est donné grand favori malgré le
risque d'une abstention très élevé après
une campagne peu dynamique il s'est
finalement décidé à appeler ses
partisans à la mobilisation
vous savez que ma décision initiale a
été d'être très discret lors de ma
campagne
ce qui m'a fait descendre dans la rue
c'est parce que certains peuvent penser
que mon attitude pourrait être perçu
comme une dévalorisation des élections
une dévalorisation de la démocratie une
absence d'invitation ou comme un signe
d'arrogance face au président sortant la
seule surprise pourrait venir du
candidat de droite populiste
andré ventouras à la tête du parti anti
système chega il a reçu le soutien de
marine le pen avec qui il assure
partager de nombreuses convictions comme
on le sait nous voulons un autre système
ne voulons rompre avec la constitution
ne prononce pas sur nous nous voulons
rompre avec la manière dans la justice
est faite pour encourager les 9 millions
huit cent mille électeurs inscrits sur
les listes électorales
les autorités ont mis en place des
équipes de volontaires celles ci sont
envoyés pour faire du porte à porte et
recueillir les bulletins de vote des
personnes placées en quarantaine ou
confinées dans les maisons de retraite
c'est un devoir civique ils se sentent
utiles fiers de participer aux élections
pour nous notre plus grande
préoccupation était qu'il y ait une
sécurité totale
cela s'est très bien passé et il était
très heureux au portugal le président
n'a aucun pouvoir exécutif mais joue un
rôle important en cas de crise politique
il peut notamment dissoudre le parlement
pour convoquer des élections
législatives anticipées
depuis l'avènement de la démocratie dans
le pays en 1974 tous les présidents
sortants ont été réélus dès le premier
tour